an historic moment for europe's common
agricultural policy the area which
follows the lion's share of the budget
parliament has co-decision powers on
this for the first time leading to tough
negotiations with member states on farm
reform
obligatory
agriculture europe however some
environmental groups complained the
opportunity to make farming far greener
was squandered charges denied by some
meps the critique is
cip reform is due for a final committee
vote in september before coming to
plenary in october or november
the nsa spying scandal including claims
that international bank transfer data
has been accessed has left some meps
debating whether a key agreement on
terrorist finance tracking might be
suspended it's irrelevant whether they
have used the opportunity so far because
they will continue to reserve that right
in the future so for me chair
the agreement is effectively dead the
commission says it needs more
information but if the allegations were
true the response should be unequivocal
if those allegations are true they
constitute a breach of the agreement and
the breach of the agreement can
certainly lead to a suspension emips
heard from several experts in this the
third hearing in the inquiry by the
civil liberties committee including i.t
industry insiders alarmed at the turn of
events i think this creates profoundly
dangerous destabilizing factors in
democracy because it means that public
opinion now has to consider
are the people of influence in society
as it were looking over their shoulder